the very first manga i ever bought was
this and in it was the 23rd tenkaichi
budokai i've spent a large portion of
what has now become my career starting
and analyzing dragon ball story and i do
not mean this lightly when i say there's
an argument to be made that this last
arc the 23rd tenkaichi budokai right
before the start of dragon ball z is the
single best arc in all of the series and
i say that as someone that's intimately
aware of what comes afterwards so if you
haven't seen this arc that acts as the
prequel to z then buckle up because
you're in for one hell of a ride this
marks the beginning of dragon ball's
best narrative streak and the peak of
akira toriyama's powers as a mangaka i
can't wait to discuss this with you all
today so let's try to do it justice
everyone welcome to our final stop this
is akira toriyama's magnum opus for his
underrated and undefeated dragon ball
the 23rd tenkaichi budokai
[Music]
[Applause]
last week when i covered the king
piccolo saga and described it as akira
toriyama's first significant dive into
villain-driven narratives prior to that
effort the closest we got to stories
surrounding big bads came in the form of
the red ribbon army and tao pai pi
neither of which were necessarily the
focus of the ark for extended periods of
time with the other arcs in the series
outside of that centered around the
world tournament formats seating the
show every single time and with good
reason they're amazing but that's what
makes this arc i'm discussing today so
brilliant and stand out in this early
dragon ball material not only does this
arc learn from and build upon the
mistakes and narrative beats in the last
arc but it manages to deliver one of the
best villain driven stories while also
being the single best world tournament
in the entire series in essence this arc
is the culmination of everything that
came before it
training with kami
this introduction between popo and goku
was honestly too iconic an opportunity
to pass up so i decided to reach out to
my good friends kaiser neko lenny peter
and massachux to help me introduce this
special character
oh wow this is the highest stuff i've
ever been
grandpa did tell me god lived in the
clouds
oh heck does that mean i'm in heaven
i wonder if i'll run into him again
are you god
not the one you're looking for oh
well
could you point me to him mr popo
mr popo could you point me to him mr
purple i could but first you must
undergo po-po's training training i love
training good then let us establish the
pecking order oh i love chicken
[Laughter]
the popo encounter once atop the lookout
is a fun affair with goku trying to
prove himself worthy of training under
kami the guardian of the earth what
stands out to me in this brief but
important encounter is that it
highlights once again goku's endearing
and innocent sensibilities when it comes
to his approach popo effectively tells
him to get lost because he deems him
weak both physically and spiritually but
in that instant goku demonstrates his
strength of spirit by taking that
criticism on the chin and using it as a
chance to train and get better leading
popo to remark
and through that character-driven choice
made by goku we learn more about the
lookout and what makes it a special
place to train
[Music]
that is what natural exposition looks
like tying beautifully into the primary
lesson learned through this portion of
the story goku wastes too much energy
through unnecessary movement and in
learning how far he truly is from their
level from the bar popo has said as a
threshold to meet in order to qualify
for training instead of pouting crying
or arguing his point goku just gets
excited at the thought of working on
himself to get stronger it's not a
matter of not being able to do it for
goku there's no self-pity there's no
self-doubt for goku he sees this as a
matter of time before he achieves his
goal that expression of enthusiasm and
eagerness to learn then acts as the
perfect character driven trigger for
kami to remark from afar that he likes
goku by simply being who he is he has
much like with his prior mentor figures
gained favor with an access to the
highest authority on earth kami
everything in this section is driven by
character from goku charting akami
thinking he's an enemy to kami's
backstory's revelation all of this
exposition is dispensed through those
natural avenues provided by the
character's driven motivations it's
honestly a remarkably efficient portion
of this tale filled with personality
philosophy and lorenzo
and with that comes an end to this
nostalgic early era of dragon ball gone
now are the days of childlike adventure
and comedy focused narratives on the
horizon now are battles hardened
villains hell bent on world conquest
with the only hope for mankind resting
squarely on the shoulders of the
generation that's been fostered in this
early material right here we say goodbye
to this brand of goku for the next time
we see him he will have grown
substantially
the 23rd tenkaichi budokai three years
later
the editor working alongside toriyama at
the time kazuhiko torishima as well as
all those involved alongside toriyama
were very much against this idea of
aging up the character mostly because it
involved completely changing the
character design of the main protagonist
this wasn't something often done and
certainly not by what was at the time
the leading manga in the industry the
old adage of if it ain't broke don't fix
it must have resonated with more than a
few surrounding toriyama at the time
however for him it was something he
desperately wanted to push forward
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
and with baited breath the team
surrounding toriyama ventured into bold
new territory however little did they
know it would usher in the dawn of a new
era one in which dragon ball would lead
the charge transforming from a brilliant
manga to something truly exceptional the
qualifying rounds describing this arc as
the best tournament in the series isn't
necessarily a controversial opinion
however i think quite a few might
struggle with effectively putting into
words what makes it so special there are
plenty of noteworthy surface level
observations to be made of course the
group of recognizable or fan favorite
warriors participating is larger than
prior tournaments and significant in
addition to us all as an audience being
eager to see what's changed in the last
three years concerning them specifically
goku seeing as he's been training under
backing order for those three years but
for me i think there's something else to
look at which makes this third and final
tournament of early dragon ball so
special the 21st 22nd and 23rd world
tournaments of early dragon ball are
perhaps the best part of the entire
series when considered as a collective
contained within these snapshots of
dragon ball's history is a three-part
coherent and heartfelt narrative driven
by a clear goal and sense of character
the 21st tournament details the
instilling of key values onto both goku
and krillin by master roshi attempting
to preserve their fighting ethic and
cement a philosophy that to this day
remains part of dragon ball's core
message fight not for status or for
glory but to better yourself and to
protect others it's elegant and it's a
resilient philosophy the 22nd tournament
then contends with the natural
progression or evolution of that very
idea seen through the lens of a mentor
basking in the twilight of his martial
arts career both he and we as an
audience discover the latent potential
of this new generation rising up as
roshi finally concedes and passes the
torch onto them this idea then reaches
its natural emotional and logical
conclusion at the 23rd world tournament
wherein the new generation of warriors
are tested not just against each other
but by their collective pasts climaxing
in a refined and might i add perfectly
integrated main villain to cap off this
era of dragon ball in a fashion never
before seen to this level in the series
it's outstanding and it all starts here
the quarterfinals casting your minds
back to the 21st and 22nd tenkaichi
budokai quarter-final rounds you'll no
doubt recall some bouts like yamcha
versus jackie chan or chiaozu vs krillin
but in reality most of those fights were
throwaway bouts that carried with them
little narrative significance outside of
some gags simply a formality that would
transport our main cast into the
semi-finals where they would no doubt
encounter much more interesting
competition goku vs giron and jackie
chun vs man wolf are certainly
quarterfinal fights that match that
billing this is however exactly what
sets this tournament apart from all
those that came before it every single
fight from the quarterfinals onwards
operates on an entirely different level
tying not just key characters together
but producing in themselves stories that
are in isolation tied to the past and in
other cases filled with mystery tao pai
pai versus ten shinhan this tournament
is honestly a terrific manifestation of
all that akira toriyama has developed
over dragon ball's lifespan utilizing
the qualifying rounds to spend some time
with tao pai pai by taking out chaos in
a fittingly cruel fashion only served to
build anticipation for his inevitable
fight with ten shinhan in the
quarter-finals with his character
intrinsically connected with tension
hun's roots in the story it made for a
perfect opening to the qualifiers by
closing the book on that part of tin
shinhan's life
[Music]
the story concerning this fight is
effectively tien coming face to face
with his past seeing it for what it
truly was and moving forward from that
the tale of a promising young man led
astray by the teachings of a ruthless
mentor is as old as time itself but when
you house the climax to that very
encounter in a tournament setting you
have for yourself the perfect recipe for
a thrilling conclusion tao comes across
as petty psychotic and eventually
pathetic as tin shinhan thanks to the
path he's taken since his departure from
the crane school now possesses more than
enough power to humiliate his former
mentor and yet he shows restraint at
every opportunity out of respect
pleading with him to resign this one
gesture then serves to highlight the
extremes of both combatants 10 shinhan
strength of character and tao's weakness
of character in the 22nd tenkaichi
budokai which featured roshi against
tenshinhan roshi demonstrated a
philosophy which led tien to ask if he
had any pride something he himself felt
he needed to rely on somewhat and in
this fight against tao tien has come
full circle he does not wish to win for
glory or for to humiliate his opponent
quite the opposite this is a painful
affair for him and he wishes for his
former mentor not to embarrass himself
any further it's a brilliant fight that
concludes in the fashion it should
highlighting for us how far ten shinhan
has come as a character and it's made
all the better thanks to the stories
that came before it 10 shinhan advances
to the semi-finals next up son goku vs
name withheld continuing the string of
iconic quarterfinals matches and another
that's rooted in the past of the dragon
ball story comes sun goku vs this
mysterious female fighter much the same
way as the prior match with ten shinhan
this fight was set up or foreshadowed in
the qualifying rounds and i love it
goku's reintroduction to the series as
an adult was a terrific and iconic scene
in its own right and it was written in
such a way that allowed us as an
audience to watch on in the know as they
goku's friends slowly discovered the
person that they were talking to was in
fact the little boy they had once known
it's a fun and playful scene which
focuses on reaction rather than mystery
but this quarterfinals match takes the
opposite approach in its effective and
iconic reintroduction of the character
chichi to the series and while this
isn't the most complicated mystery i
have no doubt it kept a few people
guessing leading up to her eventual
reveal back in the 80s this was an
impressive reveal not necessarily
because it's chichi but because it was
satisfying and i think it achieved this
level of satisfaction by way of one
crucial element that needs to be present
in all mystery reveals the audience
needs to have all the necessary
information before the reveal in order
for it to be satisfying and goku vs
chi-chi achieves this by subtly planting
plenty of hints the first most obvious
one is that of the quote promise she
keeps speaking of that's gone
unfulfilled and her being angry that
goku doesn't remember it the second
however i love the most because it's
even more subtle it's pointed out later
in the air closer to her actual reveal
but it's present long before then and
that is her accent from the first
meeting in the tournament up until the
reveal she speaks just like goku with
this thick country accent and it's
specifically that aspect of their last
meeting as children which i really
thought helped connect them in the first
place and so it's fitting how it's one
of the indications that connects them
here again this is of course in addition
to a number of other telling lines from
chichi which by the end make her
identity obvious but it really helped
this match achieve a unique sense of
identity with it effectively being
goku's proposal as usual the paneling in
action is great and i especially love
how goku never even touched her in order
to pick up the victory it's a really fun
fight rooted in history and endearing
character writing next up krillin vs
piccolo jr
[Music]
[Music]
mine i haven't seen you since you was a
baby monkey but you're a bit more ugly
than i would have expected particularly
around the face
got something for you afraid i might
have sat in it at some point but i
imagine it'll taste fine just to see
[Music]
excuse me but
who are you hoodies energy good keeper
of keyboards and mice and esports of
course you know all about esports sorry
no no
blimey mackey did you ever wonder where
your mom and dad learned it all
and what
you're a gamer marking
[Music]
15 calories 40 servings has a core of
pewdiepie go on go on try it out
consider it your first lesson
[Music]
bruh
[Music]
you're a natural gamer marcy
now let's go we need to get you to
silicon valley before your first
semester at esports
[Music]
jokes aside everyone g field has been
the best sponsor i've worked with in my
career in all honesty the people are
amazing and there's virtually no filter
or script for me to read off of as made
evident by this commercial they allowed
me to make i've tried the product and i
sincerely think it's delicious so if
you'd like to try it for yourself or
want to help out the channel click the
link in the description below thank you
everyone
[Music]
of the four fights that make up the
quarterfinals this fight between the
young turtle school student and the
reincarnation of the demon king is the
first to not take from the past in any
meaningful or direct manner like the
rest do which means this fight has to
stand on its own two feet as a great
encounter and boy does it do just that
making up for the lack of history
between these two characters akira
toriyama makes this fight one to
remember through inspired choreography
near falls and wonderfully creative
combinations from the clear underdog
krillin and in my opinion this is his
best fight in the entire series bar none
something i thought was a nice touch
with all of these quarterfinal matches
was to have goku at least on some level
involved before the ten shinon fight
took place goku reassured everyone that
ten shinon had this in the bag and was
much stronger than tao with him in the
end being proven correct in this fight
right from the top goku informs krillin
as to the strength of piccolo and to go
at him full power from the start i
thought this was a great choice as it
builds the relationship between goku and
krillin with him effectively showing
concern for his friend and lending
advice but it also helps to elevate goku
in our eyes establishing him as a man
that can accurately evaluate people it
preps us as an audience for later when
he makes more dramatic judgment calls i
really like this the fight itself
between piccolo and krillin is
phenomenal it's not the longest but it
does everything it can with the time it
has with the story of the match not
necessarily concerning itself with can
krillin win but instead can krillin
prove piccolo wrong right from the start
piccolo called krillin a quote nothing
and in many ways this assessment sort of
rings true for us as an audience too and
going into this we aren't sure if he can
do so much as anything to piccolo
the look of surprise on piccolo's face
here is something to marvel at you can
almost see him thinking oh damn i
underestimated this guy the story of
krillin throughout the story has been
that of a young kid looking to prove
himself early on this took the form of
arrogance blowing himself up cheating
and feeling deflated when he sees others
succeed where he would fail this then
naturally developed into him using that
element of his personality in creative
ways to help make up the difference
where he could by being more strategic
particularly in the 22nd tenkaichi
budokai however in addition to this
development he also was on the receiving
end of numerous attacks acting as a
punching bag for various villains and he
never managed to capture the respect of
any of them he just proved that he
wasn't on their level without putting up
much of a fight at all now of course
this fight between krillin and piccolo
comes with some terrific action and not
to mention angles this by the way is one
of my favorite action panels of the
series but the fact that this fight
ended with him having given it his all
surprised his vastly stronger opponent
and chose himself to step out with a
smile on his face highlights perhaps
better than any other choice the sort of
growth and development krillin has
undergone as a character he's gone from
an emotionally weak wannabe fighter to
one that understands his limits accepts
them and works within those boundaries
to do more than his vastly superior
opponents ever might have expected
leading piccolo to say i fear i won't be
able to conquer this world so easily
piccolo does come away with the win but
krillin leaves with his respect and next
is the final fight of the quarter finals
shen versus yamcha what i would like to
draw attention to in this fight is just
how amazing toriyama is as a writer when
he's at his best these quarterfinals all
have a unique sense of identity but they
can be paired off thematically also for
instance ten shinhan vs tau is a unique
fight with a specific tone but it shares
a theme with goku's fight alongside
chichi while being a mirror image of it
tien's fight sees him confronting a
familiar face from the past forced to
put him down because he refuses to yield
goku's fight too saw him face off
against a familiar face but not one he
remembers much the same as tien he
doesn't want to hurt his opponent and in
the end unlike 10 shinhan doesn't the
differences are here where tien hopes to
never see him again karen ties with tao
and that part of his life and with goku
very literally tying the knot with
chichi someone that will become a key
part of his life moving forward this is
a beautiful use of theme and
storytelling to help these fights flow
naturally into each other perfectly
tying the story together and this trend
continues with this fight between yamcha
and shen with it effectively being a
mirror of the fight between piccolo and
krillin going into this the narrative
brings to our attention the fact that
yamcha has never gotten past the
quarterfinals in all of the story sort
of similar to how krillin never managed
to prove himself or gain the respect of
a main villain and with yamcha's
opponent now being shen someone that
seems to have gotten in on the basis of
a fluke yamcha's feeling great about his
chances for semi-finals glory that is
until
now something i intentionally didn't
mention about shen during the qualifiers
was his elimination of a specific
character to gain the ability to appear
in the quarterfinals he defeated
yajirobe who's now sulking around the
tournament grounds like some sort of
weird lucha stalker this is clearly no
amateur and as we soon find out isn't
your average ordinary fighter either
similar to krillin yamcha finds himself
pitted against one of the strongest
fighters in the series kami hiding
within the body of a civilian to try to
take out piccolo the reveal of this
secondary plot thread added further
tension to the event's proceedings but
what it didn't do was elevate yamcha's
situation making him feel like more of
an afterthought and with strike after
strike blow after blow yamcha is looking
as though he's going to be knocked out
of bounds by the god of this world who
by the way doesn't seem to have tried
very hard at all viewing yamcha as
nothing but a stepping stone on his way
to fight piccolo later and this is where
it gets interesting as i mentioned the
story of this fight is a perfect mirror
image of piccolo's fight with krillin
both involve winners that hide their
identities to varying degrees for the
purposes of the tournament both enter
their respective battles anticipating it
to be nothing special but both get
impressed by their respective opponents
abilities with piccolo taken aback
almost immediately and kami at the very
end
in devastating fashion
[Music]
if this isn't a jump out of your seat
moment i don't know what is much like
the prior fight these pages
demonstrating the initial strike of
yanchez energy ball and the subsequent
counter by kami exemplify perfectly what
it is about toriyama's paneling that i
adore there's such a powerful sense of
movement the pages almost feel kinetic
filled with life and flow and in the end
revisiting these quarter finals i was
honestly blown away by the level of
quality present throughout with the
surprising level of thought having gone
into the encounters the themes present
and breakneck action paneling to rival
any of the other tournament fights that
came before it and with the semifinals
now approaching i think you can now
appreciate why i think the 23rd
tenkaichi budokai is a contender for the
very best arc the dragon ball series has
ever produced the semi-finals
[Applause]
son goku vs 10 shinhan
in fittingly grandiose fashion the
finals from the prior tournament are now
acting as the semi-finals for this
tournament the last time these two faced
off it was close but then shinhan
managed to squeak out a victory in the
end to win the 22nd tenkaichi budokai so
how do things measure up now well
the entire fight while great at its core
is there to show just how amazing goku
has become and i think tenshinhan was
the perfect candidate to bring that out
of the character similar to the prior
fights the paneling is stellar with some
really interesting angles and ideas
experimented with but for me i think the
largest contribution this fight made to
the series was the introduction of
weighted clothing in fights
weighted clothing wasn't necessarily a
new concept to dragon ball at this point
as it had been established during
roshi's training before the 21st
tenkaichi budokai all those years ago
however as i alluded to earlier never in
this way before this is once again
another concept or idea introduced in
early dragon ball that will become
exceptionally popular later in z
and z used to tremendous effect right
here in this scene to achieve one thing
to place goku in a position of mystery
and control throughout this tournament
no matter what match was taking place in
the quarterfinals goku would remark upon
each encounter with tremendous insight
and observation skills lending to the
idea that he is more in control and more
powerful than even we as an audience
might appreciate and that very aspect of
the story being told through this fight
is emphasized through this very action
he's been concealing his power from both
his opponent and us the readers or
viewers ten shinhan remarks beforehand
that he's impressed by goku's
improvement but that his speed is still
nothing compared to his own leading him
to outmaneuvering goku at every turn
however despite this two things remained
consistent goku never got tired and goku
never had a problem tracking his
movements and this all starts to make
sense when you realize he wasn't able to
move as fast as he wanted to placing
goku once again on another level above
everyone else which isn't an unfamiliar
position for him to be in during these
tournaments throughout the 21st and 22nd
tenkaichi budokai a key aspect of these
tournaments surrounding goku has been
that of how competent he actually is and
the stories surrounding them have been
discussing how best to overcome the
mountain he presents to the likes of
roshi and others however what makes this
arc unique when taking that aspect into
account is that unlike the previous arcs
where goku is the obstacle in this arc
goku is the point of view character the
hero we see his internal thoughts as he
tries to piece together what's going on
between shen and piccolo and even tens
shinhan and tao and that's what makes
this ark so special he's not the
obstacle piccolo is and right now
tenchinon is blocking the way to piccolo
and that long sought after a first place
spot strongest under the heavens
needless to say things aren't looking
too good for the crane school alumni but
what i really like about this section is
that tin shinhan doesn't roll over and
take this sudden show ability by goku as
an indication that he's lost he'll know
he's the defending champion instead in
response to that he whips out a move no
one has ever seen before including goku
in the past we've seen after image
techniques and we've even seen
tenshinhan grow extra limbs in the prior
bout three years ago but this time he
takes that to its natural conclusion by
splitting himself into four separate but
identical fighters and the presence of
this scene serves two purposes one to
demonstrate how tenacious gifted and
hardworking tenchinon is as a fighter
and two to show us all that goku not
only has developed physically as made
obvious earlier in the fight but that he
has sharpened his mind greatly also
i really appreciated the angle this
fight has taken it places goku once
again in the driver's seat and creates
all of this anticipation with his very
statement alone begging us the readers
to try and figure out what those two
weaknesses might actually be that he's
talking about overall this fight
delivers on just about every front it's
a terrific settling of a score produce
some wonderful paneling and showcase
some clever action writing with the
weaknesses goku exposes in this
technique not only making sense but
because they made sense it only further
cemented how much more adept a fighter
goku has become over the last three
years goku advances to the finals in
dominating fashion next up
shen versus piccolo jr
with one match between two rivals now
having reached its conclusion we press
onward to another between kami
inhabiting the body of a civilian named
shen versus the reincarnation of the
demon king his other half piccolo jr and
while it's one of the shortest
semi-final matchups its design is simple
but immensely effective these
semi-finals while interesting in their
own right with some interesting action
set pieces were designed with the clear
mission of establishing and building up
the contestants of the final match up
above all else with this fight against
shen used to outstanding effect in
helping to elevate piccolo higher than
we ever could possibly have foreseen
something you might have noticed during
this review however is that despite
having acknowledged piccolo as the main
villain of the ark i've not done much in
the way of speaking about him beyond his
relationship to kami and that's with
good reason if you were to go back
through the previous arc and this one to
compare the two incarnations of their
respective piccolos the king and the
reincarnation you'd notice that while
sharing some ideological similarities
they are markedly different piccolo jr
throughout these contests seems to have
shown some respect to his fellow
competitors on some level during
numerous fights either while watching or
participating piccolo acknowledges the
power and toughness of his opponents
going as far as to admit what he's been
proven wrong this isn't something king
piccolo would ever have done with him at
the first sign of resistance pushing
back or losing his mind to blinding
anger however when piccolo is taken
aback and shown resistance he applies
strategy and counter measures
[Music]
the fight itself is littered with some
interesting back and forth with some
telling pieces of dialogue and actions
taken it's an effective fight lending
opportunity to develop piccolo raise the
stakes of the event and even at times
elevates goku in subtle ways during the
shen vs piccolo fight on the first page
of chapter 181 after seeing the
breakneck pace of the opening to this
match everyone is left stunned roshi
krillin tenshinhan yamcha everyone
except for goku without words this helps
him stand out from the crowd ahead of
his match in the finals and on the topic
of the finals match there's a brief but
interesting back and forth between kami
and goku right before he goes out to
fight piccolo in the semi-finals and
within it the pieces are set for goku to
become the character he will remain for
quite some time into z and beyond
throughout this series goku has been a
character that when faced with
expectation and reality shatters those
expectations innovating new ways around
problems people never thought possible
at present kami doesn't think goku has
what it takes to do what he thinks he
needs to to kill piccolo jr and goku
doesn't want to kill piccolo knowing it
will in turn kill kami and there my
friends lie is the main problem of this
arc piccolo has sealed kami inside a
vial and swallowed it and now goku is
the only fighter remaining to protect
the world from the wrath of this
sinister individual but if the last
number of arcs and indeed these last
couple of fights have taught us anything
about goku is that when he's backed up
against a corner and given two options
he's the sort of character to grit his
teeth dig deep and create a third to
find another way when no one else could
this is what i call a true heroes moment
and it's all coming to a head for the
finals of the 23rd tenkaichi budokai the
finals
piccolo junior vs son goku
of all the fights in dragon ball none
other better signal the rise of the
younger generation more so than this
right here goku who surpassed his older
master and piccolo who's just dominated
kami and it all comes to a head in the
finals of a best tournament in the
series it's established early on that
goku is fighting with a self-imposed
handicap well okay actually too not only
does he want to defeat piccolo but he
needs to protect the spectators
surrounding him and in addition to that
he still wants to win the tournament all
this time as an audience we've been
focused on piccolo and the threat he
presents overcoming him and freeing kami
but goku
he just might do it something of note
also during this match is that the
battle contains the inspiration for some
of the most iconic moments and set
pieces from goku's fight with vegeta
take for example their beam struggle
during the gorge battle it's iconic but
the exact same scene took place with the
exact same framing in this battle with
piccolo and if that wasn't enough
remember goku's battle with uzaru vegeta
one massive difference between these two
battles with giant opponents is how the
scene serves goku or depicts him for
lack of a better term in the vegeta
fight as many of you might remember goku
is firmly on the back foot which
admittedly has its own benefits in it
creating additional tension moving
towards the climax but in this piccolo
fight the size disparity isn't used to
overwhelm goku but to instead subvert
the audience and prop goku up and
demonstrate how tough he is and how
intelligent he can be he openly refuses
any help from anyone else like
tenshinhan or krillin citing it as
grounds for disqualification something
he's actively trying to avoid while
trying to defend himself against piccolo
but perhaps most impressively and what
makes me prefer this version of this set
piece more is how goku uses it to
manipulate his opponent to create new
solutions never before thought of when
goku is faced with a hopeless situation
he will create a solution no one thought
was possible and he did so here not just
with his strength but with his strategy
and intelligence this is how you
communicate to your reader or viewer
that your character is strong that he's
a powerful individual not with big
numbers or screaming but showing us
firsthand the effort and misdirection he
forces piccolo to work through it's an
impressive display placing goku on a
pedestal alongside piccolo at this
moment it truly feels as though two
demigods are duking it out with no other
living being even remotely coming close
demonstrating innovations on techniques
i didn't even know i wanted like firing
the kamehameha with his feet allowing
him to free up his hands for a punch
it's incredible the creativity on
display here and despite everything
that's on the line time and again he's
forced to deny the help of anyone that
interferes now while a great and
impressive part of the story concerns
itself with goku overcoming the odds and
managing to unleash more and more
ability and power his friends never
thought he had the other half of this
battle is supplied by piccolo who in
turn shows his own brand of toughness
and grit to push through whether that be
the strength he demonstrates the
techniques he amazes us with or the
secret abilities of his race it seems
this character can create his own
alternative options when all others are
taken off the table and this tough
tenacious dynamic piccolo brings to the
table for goku brings out the best in
his character both need this victory so
much is hanging in the balance and
despite all of this goku still refuses
to treat this like anything other than a
tournament and this moment this right
here this is where goku stole piccolo's
soul it's in this moment goku steam
rising off of him and clothes tattered
after taking the very best piccolo has
to throw at him remains standing upright
before him smiling what an outrageously
brilliant fight after taking the
absolute best this warrior has goku
rallies himself one last time and with
fear in piccolo's eyes the young man
sprints towards the would-be demon king
landing a devastating elbow to his jaw
it's honestly difficult not to just sit
back and commentate over all of this
fight the panels surrounding this
section of the manga are some of the
best in the series and even our son
toyotaro himself took inspiration for
his dragon ball super manga the poses
are just incredibly dynamic the layouts
are incredible
the entire story of early dragon ball
has centered around a specific
philosophy
to not train to win but to better
yourself and to protect those that are
defenseless in the 21st tenkaichi
budokai roshi desperately wanted to
instill this lesson in the young warrior
and in doing so learned that goku was
something truly special even when he was
a small boy he could see that there was
something outstanding waiting to be
tapped into even back then it was
apparent he wasn't like the others
pushing his master to his absolute
limits in the 22nd tenkaichi budokai and
beyond goku gained the responsibility
that such power brings with it not
because he wanted it but because it was
who he was and in the face of that
alongside a new generation roshi hung up
his ghee for good for the first time in
many many many years a young boy was
able to stand up when others couldn't
and save the world three years pass now
a young man goku's limp body lays
defeated on the ground before piccolo
who's now celebrating his conquest of
the earth and in no more fitting a
fashion as kami rallies the remaining
earth's defenders to intervene life
surges back into goku
this
is what makes goku special in the face
of certain death without any usable
limbs and every option taken from him he
still finds it in him to dig deep smile
and invent a solution to the impossible
problems that stand before him no matter
how formidable no matter how terrifying
no matter the stakes no matter the odds
goku will find a way to succeed when
others can't
[Applause]
the winner of the 23rd tenkaichi budokai
is son goku
this arc sandwiched between two time
skips contains more passion skill vision
and love in many other acts in this
series and indeed many other stories
i've ever read i started this video
series in the hopes that it would shed
some light on why i loved this story so
much and i hope i've managed to
introduce at least a few of you to what
i consider to be one of the most
underrated stories to have come out of
japan this was a much needed enjoyable
trip down memory lane for me i haven't
had the best year and a half but this
story definitely has lifted my spirits
in times when nothing else could i thank
you so much for taking the time out of
your days to share it with me i don't
know what the future holds but i'm
excited i hope i'll see you there i'd
also like to thank tfs for contributing
to this video in the best of ways they
are some of the nicest most
accommodating individuals to work with
and you can find everything from their
personal twitters to their youtube
channels down below in the description